ich weiß von Straftaten
ich weiß wie sich rechtsradikal in
Deutschland bewaffnen womit sie Geld
verdienen wofür es ausgegeben wird ich
weiß wie sich rechtsmeditante Gruppen
national und international vernetzen ich
weiß wie die Szene mit ihren Feinden
umgeht und auf feinesisten setzt und ich
weiß wann und wo für den Tag extremiert
wird
woher wissen sie das alles ich war dabei
vor zwei Jahren meldet sich ein Mann er
möchte aus dem Innersten der
Neonazi-Szene berichten aber nur anonym
sein Leben selten Gefahr
wenn sie mich Michael 20 Jahre war ich
in Neonazi jetzt wirklich aus unser
Informant ist kein gewöhnlicher rechter
Aussteiger er war Teil der militanten
Neonazi-Szene die mit Terror und Gewalt
droht bei vielen
Straftäter und handelt sich um
Intensivstraftäter und man könnte es
umgangssprachlich eben auch bezeichnen
als tickende Zeitbomben als Kind wird
Michael von Rassisten indoktriniert und
zum Neonazi erzogen mir wurde dann
schnell beigebracht das was du daheim
hörst und das was ein Zeltlager
gesprochen wird das sagst Du nicht
weiter
Rechte Kameraden werden seine Freunde
Kriminelle die eine Art braune
neonazi-mafia aufgebaut haben in diesem
Größenordnung in dieser Dimension war
das was ich dann später herausstellte
war das schon etwas ganz gewaltiges mir
ist jetzt erst bewusst geworden wie groß
sie Gefahr sie für meinen alten
Kameraden ausgeht wir haben da wirklich
eine ein Aufkommen von untergrundgruppen
und rechtsradikalen Gruppen die zu
Waffen greifen zu Sprengstoff greifen
die alles in die Tat umsetzen wollen und
das macht uns Sorgen
sie sind bereit und die Gefahr wird
unterschätzt diese mehr vom Einzeltäter
ich kann es nicht mehr hören es gibt nie
Strukturen es gibt nie Mitwisser es gibt
nie Helfer und das ist nicht nur für
mich auch für andere absolut nicht
nachvollziehbar
NSU bundesweit verüben die
Rechtsterroristen Bombenanschläge und
mindestens zehn Morde
in ein Rechtsradikaler Raum Henriette
Rica ein Messer in den Hals
Einkaufszentrum fallen Schüsse neun
Menschen sterben in München
als die Polizei seine Waffen
beschlagnahmen will kommt es zu
tödlichen Schüssen
mit einem Kopfschuss getötet auf der
eigenen Terrasse
auf offener Straße in Halle nahe der
Synagoge
die tödlichen Schüsse in Hanauern
insgesamt 11 Tod rechtsextreme
Strukturen im KSK Stunden dann
Rechtsextremisten den Platz vor dem
Reichstag öffnete ein Hausbewohner das
Feuer auf die Polizeikräfte einer
rechtsextremen Gruppe Lauterbach
entführen eine rechte mutmaßliche
Terrorgruppe
und terroristischer Bedrohung
[Musik]
okay ich habe ein fix wie lässt sich ein
Neonazi interviewen dessen alte
Kameraden Vergeltung üben könnten wenn
sie herausfinden was er über die
rechtsmeditante Szene in Deutschland
auspackt
für diese Recherche erschaffen wir am
Computer einen virtuellen Menschen
Michael die echte Quelle sieht anders
aus heißt anders so wollen wir ihn
schützen damit seine Identität geheim
bleibt sein Wissen kann Menschen für
Jahre ins Gefängnis bringen und mit
dieser Szene wird sein Geständnis gleich
beginnen Michaels Kindheit die ihn
extrem prägen wird
die Bewegung des Schauspielers werden in
die virtuelle Welt übertragen
ich wusste schon wie passiert nichts
wenn ich mich klug und unauffällig
verhalte
mich erwischen die nicht ein zweiter
Schauspieler leiht Michael seine Stimme
mir ist erst jetzt bewusst geworden wie
groß die Gefahr ist die von meinen alten
Kameraden ausgeht und so sieht das dann
aus sie sind bereit und die Gefahr wird
unterschätzt
wichtige Orte seiner Lebensgeschichte
lassen wir computergeneriert nachbauen
nachgestellte Welten ein Avatar ist das
zulässig in einer Dokumentation wir
entscheiden uns für ja weil wir nur so
den echten Menschen schützen können uns
als Recherche-Team ist bewusst dadurch
die Wirklichkeit nicht präzise abbilden
zu können der Erkenntnisgewinn über die
extreme Rechte rechtfertigt aus unserer
Sicht die verfremdete Darstellung zu
Beginn unserer Recherche haben den
Michael nichts geglaubt bis wir
ausreichende Belege für seine Angaben
hatten seine Erlebnisse sind
besorgniserregend weil sie zeigen wie
organisiert und strukturiert Neonazis
weitestgehend unbeobachtet agieren über
zwei Jahre sprechen wir in ausführlichen
Interviews mit dem Aussteiger
hinterfragen in kritisch und Haken immer
wieder nach durch Michael gewinnen wir
zahlreiche exklusive Erkenntnisse und
Details darüber wie es im Innersten der
deutschen militanten Neonazi-Szene
aussieht
[Musik]
wenn wir Dir erwischtennen wird es nicht
gut für die ausgegangen
ich weiß nicht ob die Waffe geladen und
gesichert war vielleicht war es eine
Spielzeug bist du aber ich weiß es nicht
ich habe die Waffe in die Hand gedrückt
bekommen dann ist es feines Aufklärung
der Betreuer vom Camp hat uns gesagt im
Wald versteckt sich die Antifa findet
sie
wie alt waren Sie
so 13 ja ungefähr 13 14 also schon etwas
älter werden da regelmäßig waffenlehre
schon ein bisschen krass wie ein Kinder
waffenlehre Michael erinnert sich an
militärische Begriffe die aus der
Hitlerjugend stammen als Schüler wächst
er in Bayern auf wie er seine Ferien
verbringt darf er niemandem verraten in
den türkischen Zeltlager bin ich ja
quasi groß geworden mit fünf sechs
Jahren ging das ja schon los in Sommer
waren wir irgendwo im Wald und haben
gekämpft ich erinnere mich an viele
andere Kinder und Betreuer ein
Großeltern war es wichtig dass ich so
mein Sommer verbringe mein Opa war es
auch der mir das erste mal eine Waffe
gezeigt hat im Schießen gespielt
noch du musst immer damit rechnen dass
der fein kommt
Opa hat mich wirklich früher
nationalsozialistisch geprägt für mich
war das auch ganz normal dass mein Opa
mit seinen alten Kriegs Kameraden im
Lagerfeuer saß die alten
Kriegsgeschichten auspackte und mir von
der Zeit vor Schwerte
mein Opa hat immer gesagt du musst
einsatzbereit sein wenn der Feind kommt
daher kann ich den Umgang mit Luft
gewähren und Handfeuerwaffen schon
und dann irgendwann wurde es zu
Normalität
Michael sagt die Zeltlager sind mal im
Thüringer Wald an der Ostsee oder in der
Sächsischen Schweiz
organisiert werden sie konspirativ
niemand soll von den Camps erfahren wo
die Kinder Trachten tragen nach extremem
konservativen und völkischen
Rollenbildern erzogen werden soll hier
der Neonazi Nachwuchs geformt und ein
elitärer lebenslanger buntgeschmiedet
werden das klingt total authentisch weil
wir haben das ähnlich erlebt gerade bei
der heimatre in deutschen Jugend allen
Rechten lagern und Rechten
rechtsextrementen und
Organisationsstrukturen dieser Art ist
es eigentlich gemeint dass Kinder als
allererstes lernen wer sind die Feinde
und wer bedroht uns und wann endlich
bricht diese Demokratie zusammen und
unser Tag wird kommen
Expertinnen und Experten werden uns bei
der Einordnung von Michaels Erzählungen
helfen eine unsichere Faktenlage werden
wir transparent ansprechen
die Recherche ist mühsam und zäher als
andere Recherchen weil es in der
rechtsmeditanten Szene besonders
verschlossen zugeht und vieles was
Michael erlebt hat schon lange
zurückliegt
da hinten weint selbst dass sie es
Führerbunker in andere CIS Meldezentrale
daran haben die ganzen Betreuer
geschlafen wir waren meist 10 bis 20
Kinder werden viel Spaß aber auch
gesinnungsschule deswegen alles ganz
harmlos an Kochen Spiele spielen dann
wurden wir im Rassenlehre geschult das
war sehr kindlich geil ich erinnere mich
an einen Lehrgang mit wem darfst du
spielen und wen sollst du meinen
mit deutschen Kindern durfte ich spielen
mit ausländisch aussehenden nicht wir
haben auch Tradition Kultur oder braucht
uns mega gehabt die Mädchen mussten
Handarbeit lernen die Jungs mussten also
Socken Schwerter bauen mit Wein und
Bogenschießen sowas
immer von früh bis abends
sportliche tüchtigung
aber das schlimmste waren sexual
aufstehen
dann dieser wunderbare morgen Appell
noch vor dem Frühstück
wurde erstmal rum stehst dass das habe
ich ganz schön geprägt können sie
irgendwie belegen dass sie in diesen
Camps groß geworden sind nein Fotos war
nicht erlaubt ich war ein kleines Kind
aber ich gebe ihnen Namen von
Beteiligten und Details sie verifizieren
können machen wir wir werden alles
überprüfen
ja wir haben das schon lange vorgewarnt
ich mache das ja auch schon lange fast
30 Jahre mein Name ist Andrea röttke ich
bin freie Journalistin habe Politik
studiert und bin als freie Journalistin
eigentlich nur mit dem Thema
Rechtsextremismus vertraut und dort zu
Filmen zu fotografieren wo uns die Nazis
eben auch nicht haben wollen seit 2005
filmt Andrea Röpke heimlich Rechte
Jugendcamps Andreas
okay
gar nichts genaues nur die Region dann
fahren wir einfach los und suchen
Mitte der 2000er entdeckt Röpke ein
Zeltlager es erinnert an Michaels
Erzählung und wirkt wie ein
Ausbildungslager aus der Nazizeit es ist
die
Hitlerjugend verboten worden und nur
sieben Jahre nach dem Verbot der
Hitlerjugend 1952 wurde die
viking-jugend gegründet und seitdem hat
es eigentlich immer rechtsextreme
militante Kinderlager gegeben ich habe
nur Kinder getroffen die auch in
völkische Tracht angezogen waren für
mich war das was ich in der Schule
gesehen habe immer fremd mir wurde ein
Stein beigebracht das was du daheim
hörst und das was ein Zeltlager
besprochen wird das sagst Du nicht
weiter in der Schule bekommst du sonst
Ärger
und ich habe früher gelernt wenig was
sagen darf und wem ich
wie überlebe ich im Wald wie überlebe
ich ohne Strom wie verteidige ich mich
wie geht man mit der Staatsmacht der
Bundesrepublik um wie verhalte ich mich
wenn die Polizei oder der
Verfassungsschutz kommt so heißen die
Schulungen die im Lager für die älteren
Programm sind sag Michael
s Ferien werden von einer Gruppe
völkischer Siedler organisiert das sind
Menschen die sich einem völkischen
deutsch sein verschrieben haben sie sie
denn auf dem Land um jenseits der großen
Städte ein autarkes Leben zu führen nach
außen wirken völkische Siedler oft
einfach rückwärts gewandt und
traditionell
aber keinesfalls gefährlich
das sind schon keine bildungsfernen
Schichten die dort ausbilden das sind
sehr akademisch geprägte Strukturen das
sind häufig Leute auch die durchaus eine
Bundeswehr Karriere die im Staatsdienst
sind die
Oppo wissen wovon sie reden und die
Kinder funktionieren auch in der
Gesellschaft die Kinder gehorchen die
Kinder lernen gleich das
Opferbereitschaft für das Volk wichtig
ist das ist auch das Besondere warum sie
wahrscheinlich auch so lange mitmachen
und so wenig von ihnen aussteigen
lange Zeit fällt niemandem auf wie weit
rechts michaelsgruppe eingestellt ist
bei der Organisation die als
Vertriebenen Verband Auftritt ziehen
Neonazis die Strippen
sie haben die Organisation unterwandert
um wieder eine reine vermeintlich allen
anderen Menschen überlegene deutsche
Volksgemeinschaft zu gründen wir
recherchieren und finden einen weiteren
Aussteiger er bestätigt ein Großteil von
Michaels Aussagen der Patch der
völkischen Siedler ist der erste der
sich zu Michaels Lebensgeschichte
aufnäht weitere Gruppen weitere Aufnäher
werden folgen und aus der weißen Weste
eines jungen Mannes jemanden Form der am
Ende für schwerst kriminelle Neonazis
Waffen schiebt
Michaels Wissen über die rechtsmeditante
Szene ist außergewöhnlich
er lernt rechte Gruppen kennen die
teilweise miteinander konkurrieren und
so verschworen und konspirativ agieren
dass so gut wie nie etwas nach draußen
trinkt
werden heute noch Kindern rechten
gesinnungscamps erzogen die Frage
stellen wir den Organisatoren von
Michaels Ferienlager eine Antwort
bekommen wir nicht
diese Aufnahmen sind aus dem letzten
Jahr auf dem Gelände eines bekannten
holocaustleugners zählten Kinder
werden auch Sie gedrillt und geschult
sowie Michael wir wissen es nicht
gesagt es wird zu wenig hingesehen
das ist kein einschreiten gibt und das
Kinder eigentlich immunisiert werden
gegen die Demokratie dass sie uns
entzogen werden das radikalisiert werden
und dass sie wahrscheinlich die
Straftäter Gewalttäter und die
gefährlichen rechtsextremen von morgen
sein können später war dann vom Tag X
der Tag der kommen werde die Rede
mir wurde häufig gesagt ihr müsst wissen
und wen ihr euch anschließen könnt aber
beste Strukturen den ihr euch anschließt
hat einen festen Plan
habe deine Exit-Strategie wie am
schnellsten zu eurer Gruppe kommt und
wisst innerhalb der Gruppe wer wir was
zuständig ist da wurde dafür mehr drauf
geguckt wer kann was in dieser Welt Tag
X das beschreibt den Tag an dem
rechtsextreme wieder die Macht
übernehmen wollen ab dem Jugendalter an
sind rechts geprägte Kinder seine
Freunde die wurden auch so erzogen wie
ich ich musste mich da nicht erklären da
habe ich mich wohl gefühlt ich kannte
Umsturzpläne werden in sein Leben lang
begleiten mit seinen Freunden fährt er
nicht nur in die Ferien sondern auch
schon bald zur rechtsrock-konzerten das
wird sein erwachsenes ich prägen
dieses Gefühl hört sich bescheuert an
aber
auf einem Konzert zu stehen wo um dich
herum alle das Gleiche wollen alle das
gleiche Gefühl haben und diese Kraft
erzeugen
es ist mega geil
24,7 habe ich nur Hass im Kopf gehabt in
der Sprache mit meinen Kameraden in der
Familie auch das was ich auf Facebook
und so sehe ist alles hasse erfüllt
damit bin ich aufgewachsen
Rechtsrock sind für mich gesprochene
Bilder
die extreme Rechte funktioniert nicht
ohne Musik die extrem rechte ist die
rechtsextreme und umgekehrt und vielen
Tasten niedrigst Musikwissenschaftler an
der Abteilung Musikwissenschaftler
Johannes Gutenberg-Universität Mainz und
klar arbeite seit gut 15 Jahren zum
Thema Rechte Musik Rechtsrock also die
einzelmusikerinnen der verschiedenen
Bands sind letztendlich genauso
aufgestellt wie die extrem rechte Szene
insgesamt der Großteil ist irgendwie
organisiert in
rechtsoristischen Organisation
Rechtsrock ist ein bundesweites Phänomen
aktuell werden die Konzerte wieder mehr
Michael waren seinen aktiven Jahren auf
vielen
150 bis 200 Konzerte werden das schon
gewesen sein oft war ich einfach als
Besucher da ich kannte aber die ganzen
Leute Rechtsrock ist nicht nur Musik
sondern auch ein Geschäft die
Haupteinnahmequelle der extrem rechten
wie viel Geld umgesetzt wird können
Behörden seit Jahren nicht genau angeben
beim kleinen Konzert haben wir drei bis
5000 Euro eingenommen
bei großen Festivals wird zwischen
30.000 und 150.000 Euro Umsatz gemacht
es ist ganz ganz schwer wirklich seriös
mit Zahlen zu arbeiten weil uns da
einfach die relevanten Informationen
fehlen hier eine Schätzung der NGO
Counter extreme project etwa 1,5 bis 2
Millionen Euro wurden 2018 geschätzt
umgesetzt bei bundesweit 35.000
Besuchern die Zahlen beschreiben Umsätze
wie hoch der Gewinn bei solchen
Veranstaltungen ist ist nicht bekannt
fest steht Konzerte sind für das
Überleben der neonazi-strukturen extrem
wichtig sie reinvestieren die Einnahmen
der Konzerte in Immobilien
Produktion von CDs
Klamotten und man kann Seltenheit
und was übrig blieb das dient der
persönlichen Bereicherung letztendlich
finanziert sich die Szene über die so
generierten Umsätze
dasselbe Deutschland hat die größte
Rechtsrock-Szene weltweit weitere
Einnahmequellen für Rechtsextreme sind
Versandhandel von Propagandamaterial
Musik merchandise Immobilien Security
Business organisierte Kriminalität und
kampfsportveranstaltungen es ist
wirklich nicht nachvollziehbar warum man
solche Konzerte mit solchen
hasserfüllten Botschaften immer wieder
stattfinden lässt Konzerte werden aus
verschiedenen Gründen
selten verboten
ein Grund ist
relativ banal dadurch dass die
landestine angekündigt werden ist es
relativ schwer für ordnungs-
für die Polizei ist das oft ein Katz und
Mausspiel die klandestin organisierten
also heimlichen Konzerte zu finden
einfachste ist erstmal das Ganze unter
dem anderen Tarnmantel veranstalten zu
lassen das Ganze umzubenennen sehr fing
es dann an mit Geburtstagsfeiern dann
würden uns Hochzeitsfeiern und danach
war es so dass sie tatsächlich sehr
lange auch
schleusungspunkte bekannt gegeben haben
das heißt
man die BesucherInnen wurden dann an den
schleusungspunkten in Empfang genommen
und man ist meistens in Kolonne dann zu
einem geheimen Ort gefahren den Behörden
sind heute 150 Rechtsrock Bands und 60
Liedermacher in Deutschland bekannt
veranstaltet werden die Konzerte von
unterschiedlichen Organisationen der
rechten sukkultur aber auch von rechten
Parteien und während Michaels Kindheit
von der heute verbotenen Gruppe Blatt
andorner während andere Jugendliche zu
Konzerten der Backstreet Boys gehen hält
er sich dort auf wo sich der Rechte
blood and order das steht für Blut und
Ehre und ist ein weltweites Netzwerk
welches Konzerte von Rechten Bands
organisiert sie glauben an einen
Rassenkrieg und wurden Mitte der 90er in
Deutschland aktiv
das Michaels erstes Konzert ausgerechnet
bei dieser militanten und rassistischen
Organisationen stattfand können wir
heute nicht mehr belegen es ist schlicht
zu lange her
belegen können wir das eher andere
Konzerte besucht hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zeigt die internationalen Vordenker von
Blood and owner schnell wird klar dass
sich die Organisation gegen die
verfassungsmäßige Ordnung richtet und
daher seit 2000 in Deutschland verboten
ist
nennt sich die militante und bewaffnete
Schutztruppe vom blood and order C18 das
steht für Kampfgruppe Adolf Hitler die
gefährlich die Gruppe ist zeigt dieses
Video
verboten wird combatine erst 2020 10
Jahre nach der Mutterorganisation die
auch heute noch als eine Art Dachverband
der rechten Musikszene gilt
also das Verbot gegen Blatt in Anna bei
herzig also das es waren eigentlich ein
Witz weil es hat immer Fortführung
gegeben Verbote werden in Deutschland
Medien würden zusammen inszeniert und
danach ist Schluss danach schaut niemand
mehr hin wir haben ja auch bemerkt das
kommt bei a-teen erst unter Druck nach
den Anschlägen von Hanau und Halle nach
dem Mord am Walter Lübcke hat man combat
18 in Deutschland verboten also es kann
alles nicht wahr sein dass ich solche
Strukturen so militantisch Strukturen
eben auch so stark entwickeln können und
gar nichts eigentlich kaum etwas
befürchten müssen haben Neonazis in
Deutschland nichts zu befürchten
Michael wird uns weiter aus dem
Innersten der extrem rechten berichten
von Waffen Trainings im Innen und
Ausland
schauen die Behörden halbherzigen
bei mir hätte Verfassungsschutz aktiv
zugesehen wie ich immer weiter in die
Szene reinrutschte die wollte mich nicht
davon abhalten
oder mir einen Ausweg zeigen denn
einziges Interesse war es Informationen
zu bekommen
der Verfassungsschutz hat mich mit 15
das erste mal angesprochen ob ich nicht
mehr mit ihm sprechen möchte ich sei
doch schon wieder rumgekommen und ich
kenn doch auch schon ein paar Leute und
Organisationen
ich habe mich umgedreht und bin gegangen
das war ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz
insgesamt würde ich bestimmt zehnmal
angesprochen
wie viel Geld ich hätte verdienen können
meine Kameraden und ich wären das immer
ausgeschlossen und es gab andere die das
eben genutzt wenn sie Geld braucht und
dann sich vom Staat bezahlen lassen das
wussten alle
als Rechercheteam konfrontieren wir das
zuständige Landesamt für
Verfassungsschutz und fragen ob Mitte
der 90er Jugendliche angesprochen worden
es heißt darüber legen keine
Erkenntnisse vor detaillierte Nachfragen
könnten Michael als Quelle gefährden aus
dem völkischen Kind das den Umgang mit
Waffen lernt ist in den 2000ern ein Mann
geworden das sind Freunde extrem rechts
sind er ist ideologisch gefestigt nimmt
an aufmärchen teil und schon bald lernt
er Neonazis aus Österreich kennen die
Feinde mit Skorpionen bedrohen und
Zugang zu Kriegswaffen haben
wir sind immer sehr konspirativ
vorgegangen in Wagen mit den Waffen ist
eigentlich immer die Freundin von einem
aus der Gruppe gefahren
was ist denn den schwarzen Taschen im
Kofferraum
es geht dann umgeschriebenes Gesetz wer
angehalten wird hat Pech gehabt alle
anderen fahren dann weiter haben sie
Angst erwischt zu werden
die Polizei hält uns nur ganz selten an
wenn wir zum Steinbruch fahren und eine
Person hat ja auch immer einen
Waffenschein
wichtig ist es immer zwei Wege zum
Steinbruch führen ein Fluchtweg muss es
immer geben es kommt schon mal vor dass
die Polizei auftaucht weil
Waldspaziergänger Schüssel gehört haben
aus den Bekanntschaften werden schnell
Freunde Michael gilt als
vertrauenswürdig und deshalb nehmen sie
ihn mit zur geheimen schießtrainings
damit wir den Weg zum Steinbruch finden
haben wir die Bäume markiert die
Steinbrüche sind schwer zu erreichen da
gibt's keine offizielle Straße meist
sind die Steinbrüche nicht mehr im
Betrieb oder es wird nur am Tag abgebaut
wir haben auf alles Mögliche geschlossen
auf Dosen oder so also wenn du ein
Anfänger bist ist das Ziel umso größer
und wenn du dann erstmal geschossen hast
wurde die Ziele immer kleiner sozusagen
die meisten haben sich immer
irgendwelche politischen Feinde
vorgestellt
irgendwelche Leute die sie hassen
Lokalpolitiker oder so und wenn jemand
zufällig vorbeikommt ist hier in den
Steinbrüchen eher selten sind sie zu der
Zeit eigentlich auch privat bewaffnet
ja ich habe da Pistole
seit 2006 sei er regelmäßig in die
Steinbrüche in Österreich nahe der
deutschen Grenze gekommen mehr als zehn
Jahre lang Michael und seine Freunde
trainieren für den Tag X mal auf dem
Schießstand mal im Steinbruch oder im
Wald sie wollen vorbereitet sein
Tag X das beschreibt kein konkretes
Datum und wird innerhalb der rechten
Szene unterschiedlich verstanden die
einen warten auf diesen Tag andere
arbeiten darauf hin
in einer Krisensituation soll ich
Waffengewalt ein neuer Staat nach dem
Vorbild des Nationalsozialismus
geschaffen werden ein Staatsstreich
für diesen trainieren und bewaffnen sich
manche weil sie genau diese Krise selbst
auslösen möchten
2020 haben laut Innenministerium mehr
als 1.000 Rechtsextremisten legal Zugang
zu Waffen unklar ist wie viele
unregistrierte
illegale Waffen Michaels Kameraden
besitzen
Michael knüpft mit den Jahren Kontakt zu
weiteren Rechten und verrät was sie sich
einfallen lassen um unentdeckt von den
Behörden zu bleiben und sich zu
vernetzen
in Deutschland lernt Michael Mitglieder
eines sehr exklusiven Kreises von
Neonazis kennen Brigade 8
wie genau Michael ist Beziehung zu der
Bruderschaft ist die einem Rockerclub
ähnelt können wir aus Gründen des
quellenschutzes nicht verraten bei
Brigade 8 gibt es einen Präsidenten
Mitglieder unterschiedlichen Ranges und
Anwärter sie gelten als gefährlich
seitdem klar ist dass sie mit der
Terrororganisation combat A-Team
gemeinsame Sache machen
[Applaus]
spannend ist Brigade 8 nicht wegen der
Bands die auf diesem Rechtsrock Festival
spielen oder der Lieder die hier
gesungen werden
wir zitieren
wir wecken die Kräfte die in euch wohnen
die schüren bis zur Weißglut die
Emotionen in unseren Adern kocht
Wikinger Blut in unseren Texten steckt
nordische Wut die Verschwörung ist
bereit neue deutsche Fröhlichkeit
spannend ist was abseits solcher
vermeintlich harmlosen Musikfestivals
passiert Brigade 8 und die verbotene
Gruppe combat Eutin nutzen solche
Konzerte als Schutzraum
zum Beispiel in Ostritz einem Dorf in
Ostsachsen hier findet 2019 eines der
größten rechtsrock-festivals statt das
Schild und Schwert das Polizeiaufgebot
ist gigantisch denn hier trifft sich
Deutschlands militante Neonazi Szene
mehr als 750 Personen organisiert wird
es vom stellvertretenden
Bundesvorsitzenden der rechtsextremen
Partei NPD Thorsten Heise
während die Behörden den Fokus auf das
Musikfestival legen treffen sich die
geheim Bruderschaft und die
Terrororganisation im Nachbarort reden
da geht es um die Produktion von neue
Rechte Musik aber auch im organisierte
Kriminalität wer hat große Konzerte Feed
Polizei binden trifft sich Brigade 8
gerne mal ein paar Kilometer weiter mit
den Kameraden von comebacken
da ist dann eben keine Polizei mehr
können Sie mir mehr berichten
vor oder nach dem Festival sind wir zum
Schießen nach Polen da sind wir erst auf
dem Polenmarkt essen gegangen weil es
echt gut und billig ist und dann habe
ich schießen es wird also geplant und
trainiert klingt als sein
schießtrainings etwas Normales
ja viele Gruppen über die ich euch Infos
gebe trainieren anwaffen das ist normal
als öffentlich bekannt und was der
Verfassungsschutz auch bestätigen kann
stimmt der sächsische Verfassungsschutz
kontrolliert beim Festival zwar die
Liedtexte die gegrillt werden aber
schießtrainings könne man nicht
bestätigen was wissen die Geheimdienste
was nicht
der sächsische Verfassungsschutz lehnt
ein Interview ab der Präsident des
Thüringer Verfassungsschutzes stellt
sich unserem fragen denn jeder einzelne
jede einzelne extremistin oder Extremist
die im Gesetz legaler Waffen sind
natürlich auch illegaler Waffen sind
gefährlich mein Name ist Stefan Kramer
ich bin seit Dezember 2015 Präsident des
Amtes für Verfassungsschutz in Thüringen
und insofern glaube ich muss man den
Beweis nicht noch weiter erbringen dass
Waffen in den Händen von
Rechtsextremisten immer auch mit einer
großen Wahrscheinlichkeit eben
Todesfälle zur Folge haben Kramer
bestätigt sein Amt wisse von
schießtrainings bei denen deutsche
Neonazis mit Kriegswaffen im Ausland den
Aufstand üben schießtrainings wie
Michael sie beschrieben hat das Problem
ist natürlich an dieser Stelle dass sie
beispielsweise in Ungarn oder in
Tschechien ganz andere waffenrechtliche
Bedingungen haben so dass eine
einschießen mit
unterwegswaffen hier in der
Bundesrepublik völlig undenkbar bzw
gesetzlich sanktioniert ist aber in
diesen Ländern quasi eine
Freizeitgestaltung ist also insofern ist
schlicht und ergreifend das Problem dass
wir diese Dinge feststellen beobachten
können aber sie eben im Ausland
teilweise auch nicht strafbar sind
der Verfassungsschützer gibt offen zu
dass ein Amt nicht alles mitbekommt was
die Szene treibt
die Erkenntnisse der Behörden im Bezug
auf Waffen sind nach unserer Recherche
extrem dünn der Verfassungsschutz ist
als eine Art Frühwarnsystem gedacht der
Geheimdienst soll Gefahren von rechts
erkennen und die Demokratie beschützen
doch mehr als insgesamt 7000
Mitarbeitende konnten zahlreiche
Anschläge von rechts nicht verhindern
hat der Staat gelernt wir werden die
Ämter unentwegt konfrontieren wenn man
weiß wie viele Extremisten Waffen
besitzen warum nimmt man sie ihn nicht
weg
wir sind jetzt seit ungefähr zwei Jahren
sehr ja intensiv mit den Waffenbehörden
gemeinsam unterwegs die entsprechenden
Waffen Erlaubnisse zu prüfen
Zuverlässigkeit in der Regel zu
entziehen und dann entsprechende
Verfahren einzuleiten und die Waffen zu
entziehen dass alles hört sich genauso
langwierig an wie ich es jetzt
beschrieben habe und ist auch mit
einigen Mühen versehen weil die
Regelungen im Waffenrecht insbesondere
was die Zuverlässigkeit angeht für
Extremisten zumindest noch Hintertüren
offen gelassen hat die auch sehr
reichlich von den betroffenen Personen
vor den Verwaltungsgerichten genutzt
werden fakt ist der Waffen besitzt kann
damit agieren und die Planung der Szene
für einen Tag X ist schon lange keine
abstrakte Spinnerei mehr uns ist bekannt
dass es in den vergangenen Monaten und
Jahren diverse Versuche gegeben hat von
Gruppierungen in den Besitz von Waffen
zu gelangen diese natürlich
vorübergehend konspirativ zu lagern um
dann
zugegebener Zeit darauf entsprechend
zurückgreifen zu können es ist uns Gott
sei Dank bisher gelungen in einer
hervorragenden Zusammenarbeit der
Behörden sowohl Polizei als auch
Nachrichtendienste immer frühzeitig
solche Gruppierungen zu erkennen und
ihnen dann im Grunde ihre Arbeit kaputt
zu machen aber ich will nicht
ausschließen dass unter der Decke im
Dunkeln fällt noch eine ganze Reihe von
Aktivitäten stattfinden und deswegen
müssen wir an der Stelle sehr sehr
wachsam bleiben
mit Mitte 20 pflegt Michael Kontakt zu
verschiedenen rechten Gruppierungen in
Deutschland und in Österreich
man kennt sich man vertraut sich schon
bald steigt Michael auf und bekommt neue
Aufgaben Hannes
aus einem Mitläufer der mit Waffen
trainiert wird ein Komplize er wird
erfahren wie Waffen geschmuggelt werden
er vertrauenswürdig waren gut bezahlte
bekommt auch was
was wir tatsächlich Wissen über die
Waffenfunde ist immer nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs
wer solche Männern von Waffen hortet ist
entweder ein Verrückter Waffen geiler
waffenar oder die Person wollen solche
Waffe verwenden
so wie der die Waffen transportiert hat
war das ein sicheres nehmen
Michael wird Teil einer Art braunen
neonazi-mafia und versteckt laut eigener
Aussage rechts Terroristen vor der
Kontrolle der Polizei das ist hier eine
sehr enge Verbindung nicht nur
persönliche kennverhältnisse sondern ja
eine jahrzehntelange unterstützungs-
die Bullen kommen gleich rein machen
Kontrolle
ihr wollt mehr von den Geständnissen
eines Neonazis Teil 2 und 3 findet ihr
jetzt in der ZDF Mediathek Klick dafür
einfach auf den Link